blow into welcome to this video playing
aqaba in the house and we play Spanish
no scotch wow he's a scotch player
usually so we have a heavily and Spanish
game I'm testing out this g3 a g6 line
at the moment d3 is not very aggressive
against this but of course it's its
natural moves d 3c3 you can always play
that in their way ok so maybe a six give
me some additional options and oh it
takes it ok ok so here some things
possible Queenie 7 or f6 let's do this f
64 I wasn't wasn't clear to me ok maybe
see 593 I like to play like f6 and c5 I
think I'm going for this down now c5 ok
maybe in still 93 this type of position
is well known from many lines in the in
the way the Berlin with d3 and some
others
yeah regrouping by the night the thing
is I'm not sure what I should do your
castle short or long i think i'm going
to Castle long here it's an unusual
choice that black normally does not have
your usually committed to short
counseling early on and here i can also
go long yeah I think I'll go I'll go
with long castles short castles just I
mean why does thinking about G Freud and
yeah stuff like that anyway so it's
probably not a bad idea to castle on the
Wonder on the queenside ok um is a g5 no
I'll take them so I have to have some
time yet you coordinated this one ok mmm
so g5 I thought f5 should be so kind of
okay isn't it maybe it isn't but
hmm what to do here I can go bishop age
60 let's go then shouldn't be bad I
activate this g5 I think I can take on
c4 then take one g5
yeah I can't play many many more okay he
goes for that it's a challenging move
really is so I'm taking this and I
thought I'm just grabbing g5 which he
definitely has some idea against I don't
know what it is we'll see so just take
on f6
okay if I take there and grab on g5 what
is the deal I don't said let's I'm just
I'm just taking it now 25 at the end I
don't know okay i can print with that
grabbing there anyway okay night takes
there is night exit five but I thought I
just take with the bishop what is what
is the deal Queen know if II 23 that's
rock da de something like that there's
no way rook t5 maybe but push it at 6k
yeah wonder if you get some kind of
direct direct play now otherwise I'm
very happy look at his happiness
probably in the the thing but here is
this is too loose now it's dirty and now
I can actually move the knight to f3 for
example m3 is actually an interesting
spot yep 494 it possible you can take
check and so on okay did not happen um
so 95 taking g6 I didn't see that didn't
see that coming okay so I have to cover
it first and then go to deform g5g for
would be cool if I could get that in
kind of let's try get the night covered
Queen has quite cannot do that much
let me let me think for a moment here
and see if I can't do something now but
this is this is a good I think check the
rook and take a form is there anything
better I don't see it but this looks
good he doesn't have a single Queen move
Queen g2 that's 92 check and age 43 in
g2 if i go here then look the aid i can
get i can i can get the look in look at
this and the Queen still has no move so
my ideas look the one and maybe then
clean air for something along these
lines yeah so rock t1i Bishop takes
maybe mmm I can't go age for first maybe
edge floor first pushing the Queen to g2
and then whoop do you one yeah this is
good there should be five high quality
too well okay that should be good I hope
I threaten rook g100 didn't see the
checkpoint I hope it's no big deal yeah
look here right this is winning the
Queen I'm not overlooking something
something stupid it should win the Queen
white resign yeah there I'm not sure
what it looked like a decent game this
g5 was probably mistimed I think the
position was quite equal and around here
it's probably quite equal and I don't
think that g5 was really working here so
here gen engine agrees and just grab the
porn be a pawn up why doesn't have much
here yeah it just minus one in the
computer wants to play exactly like i
did so it it looks decent thank G 5-2
all the way this this age from our
taking immediately is good I'm just
checking about made some mistake here
with with the engine but yeah just
climbing up and not 2-10 yeah then this
is not very ambitious how he played this
but it's something that I can do in lots
of rural lines take on c6 and play this
kind of structure which is very
difficult to to change but like yeah you
just sit in the structure and I mean
like is ok but it's not something
brilliant yeah ok I was happy that he
activated allowed me to activate this
but g5 is probably a bit too ambitious
you should play some normal move even
Bishop tutu
not such a bad idea trying to trade a
bishop of this Bishop is not worse than
this Bishop quite clearly I can put it
here for example looking at this
covering this so I think trading isn't a
bad strategy for him but he he probably
miscounted something with g5 okay well
thanks for watching